for all these reasons which are set out
more fully in the Judgment of the Court
unanimously concludes that the proposed
Bill does relate to reserved matters
accordingly in the absence of any
modification of a definition of reserved
matters
by an order in council under Section 30
of the Scotland act or otherwise
the Scottish Parliament does not have
the power to legislate for a referendum
on Scottish independence
okay quick uh snap analysis 30 seconds
from Akash who's been with us in the
studio thoughts
that's a very clear unanimous as the as
the president stated uh decision that
the referendum has proposed by Scottish
government cannot go ahead this now gets
kicked back into the the political Arena
I suspect okay Conor is with us at
holyrood uh no Indie ref 2 next October
Connor
uh this is uh probably the biggest
political uh constitutional moment here
in Scotland in very many years and let
me just remind you the main points of
what Lord read the president of the
Supreme Court said there he said this
was a unanimous uh judgment it was in
the public interest to make this ruling
uh which was the Scottish government's
argument all along here and they were
dealing only with the legal consequences
of this he says it was not hypothetical
it was not premature as the UK
Government tried to argue in that court
case last month in London to make a
ruling on this and he also recognized
that while there's legal ruling today is
strictly on a legal basis it does have
wider ramifications that of course head
into the political sphere but he was
absolutely clear unanimous Lord Reid
said that it does meet the test of being
a reserve matter and in that case at the
Scottish Parliament here behind me does
not have the Paris allegedly for a
second Scottish independence referendum
this is a big blow to First Minister
Nicholas sturgeon's case for holding a
second vote on the 19th of October next
year that was the plan of attack from
the Scottish national party and from the
Scottish government of course who have
won every election north of the Border
here in recent years standing on that
basis that they would be pursuing a
second vote so this will be a blow I
don't think it will be entirely
unsurprising because the Lord Advocate
herself who is the top law officer law
advisor to the Scottish government said
that she couldn't make this ruling and
that is why it was sent to the Supreme
Court so they're probably not entirely
surprising however it will be
disappointing for Nicholas sturgeon and
her Scottish government what happens
next is absolutely crystal uh is
absolutely
um you know one to be determined in the
coming hours Nicholas sturgeon has been
seeing all along that if the court made
this judgment that it was not within the
competence of Hollywood here to rule on
that then she would use the next general
election as a de facto Independence
referendum now Paul opposition
politicians have been saying that they
would not go along with that they would
not play ball with that so it'd be very
interesting to see in the coming hours
what exactly both sides of this debate
have to say because this Independence
question whatever way you come down on
the issue whether it's yes no unionist
or nationalist is absolutely through
every aspect of issues that are debated
here at Hollywood whether it be the
National Health Service whether it be
the Education Service the issues on both
sides are intertwined and it will be
very interesting to see exactly what
happens in the coming hours but a career
a crystal clear argument and case there
from the Supreme Court that Hollywood
does not have the power to legislate for
a second Scottish independence
referendum without westminster's consent